in the last video I gave the example of
this Bank that I keep using and in this
example as opposed to giving the gold
out to make loans and be used for
projects and that gold get redeposited
and then relent out what we did in this
example is that the bank every time it
made a loan it just made a loan and that
created an asset and then it had a
corresponding liability where the
liability was either a checking account
that the entrepreneur could use or bank
notes or which are essentially cash that
the entrepreneur could use to pay their
labourers or to buy their land or
whatever they needed to do so an obvious
question was how much could a bank do it
when when does this stop can a bank just
keep increasing the left and right hand
sides of the balance sheets and to
answer this question we'll introduce the
idea of a reserve ratio so just a I
guess a bit of a review and just make
sure we're clearly reading this balance
sheet and let me label things a little
bit more because sometimes I assume too
much
remember this is these are the assets
the assets are all of these me make a
bold line here all of this is the assets
of this Bank including its building so
it's vault down there and then the
liabilities I'll do that in this yielded
in round like this red colors little
blight but these are the liabilities
over here in this red color that I'm
coloring in right now
and the equity whoever owns the bank
whether stockholders or maybe it's owned
by an individual maybe it's owned by me
is what's left over this is the I call
doing a nice neutral color this is the
equity so the question is how much can
the bank and of course this let me do
all of this for liabilities liabilities
so the question is how much can the bank
continue to issue out more loans and
increase its assets and liabilities
remember every time it is you're alone
like for here right right here is issued
a 100 gold piece
2d and instead of giving D 100 gold
pieces from say right here it just
created a checking account for D which
later D paid to a and that's why it's
labeled a right here and let me real
able another thing because the gold is
different colors just so you see the
gold this is all this is the gold part
of the assets let me make that very
clear that all of this right here is
gold
maybe I'll colored in a little bit
that's all golden there's 500 gold
pieces 500 gold pieces so let's
introduce the concept of a reserve ratio
reserve ratio now let's think a little
bit about what what even though reserve
is a reserve is something that you keep
aside because you might need it one day
all right and in this situation all of
these liabilities whether they're these
banknotes outstanding in this example or
whether they're these checking accounts
these demand accounts these are all
liabilities that someone can come back
to the bank on any given day and say hey
I want my gold now for whatever reason
maybe I'm leaving town maybe I don't
trust the bank anymore
for whatever reason maybe they just want
to build some make some jewelry for
whatever reason that person wants their
gold back these are demand accounts
these checking accounts are demand
accounts and these notes are things that
can be exchanged for goal
any point in time and we talked a little
bit about this earlier when we started
the whole banking discussion but you
have to leave aside a little bit of gold
just in case someone someone wants their
gold back so this amount of the gold
that you have to leave aside as a
reserve relative to the total amount of
demands you have on that gold that's the
reserve ratio so the reserve ratio and
in this situation this world that we've
created the the reserve the reserve
store value is gold later on we're going
to get ourselves off of this gold system
and then that reserve that reserve for
value is actually going to turn into to
cash but for right now and I think it's
easier actually to conceptualize gold
let's stick with gold the reserve ratio
is for this bank is the amount of gold
assets you won't see this formal
definition anywhere because no one most
people are off the gold standard right
now but it's the amount of gold assets
divided by total I don't want to say
total liabilities because the bank could
take out loans that aren't demand loans
everything on the liabilities right now
are on demand loans which means whoever
has that liability can come back and
exchange it for gold at any moment in
time but we could the bank could have
taken just a regular loan and a regular
loan might not be on demand a regular
loan might be a loan that the bank
doesn't have to pay back for ten years
and in which case there's there's no
reason why the bank would have to set
aside some gold to pay that back so
let's let's make our definition not
total liabilities but total demand
liabilities total demand liabilities
look but liabilities whoops
liabilities so what would be total
demand liabilities that would be total
total bank notes
in this case and banknotes are also
something will you know what will later
leave a world where every bank is
issuing banknotes but I just wanted to
give you that kind of historical context
how banknotes even started off total
banknotes and demand accounts demand or
checking accounts demand checking
accounts so let's see what it is for
this Bank that we have here so our total
gold assets are 500 and what star total
demand accounts this ISA a hundred plus
100 plus 100 plus one is let's see one
two three four hundred six hundred and I
think this was another hundred year
seven hundred so it equals see the total
demand liabilities I just figured out
was seven hundred and the gold assets in
this Bank are five hundred 500 so right
now the reserve ratio of this Bank is is
pretty high five seven so I don't know
what five seven is five seven seas I
don't know seven goes into five how many
times sixty positive I'm doing my mental
math right it's about 62% seven goes
into 50
no no 7 goes into 50 seven times seven
times so it's like seventy-one percent
right 7 times 7 is 49 71% so that's this
reserve ratio and what keeps banks from
just keep issuing more assets and debts
to expand its balance sheet is a reserve
ratio requirement so right now in the
United States although we're not on the
gold standard but you could imagine in
this world our bank regulators might
might say that your reserve ratio on
demand accounts so the amount of gold
you have to set aside for checking
accounts so reserve requirement we'll
call it let me change colors just to
ease the monotony reserve requirement
they might say the reserve requirement
is equal to let's say they want to be
safe let's say they want to be they want
to make it 20% in the US right now it's
10% although the reserve commodity isn't
gold anymore let's say
20% that means as long as in on any
given at any given moment in time more
than 20% of these people don't demand
their money back the bank's going to
have liquidity the banks bill is going
to be able to fulfill its promise
because all of these people think at any
given moment they can go to the bank and
get their gold and in order for this
system to work there has to be
confidence and in order for them to be
confident the bank has to be good for it
every time someone asks for their money
so the bank has to stay liquid so
essentially this reserve ratio is what
the regulators think that a bank needs
to maintain in order to maintain be
liquid our bank as it is right now it
has a reserve ratio of 71% so as long as
no more than 71% of these people because
some of these loans these might be out
for a year or two so as long as in that
year or two that these loans are out as
long as no more than 71% of these people
come asking for don't come asking for
their gold we should be okay if all of a
sudden for whatever weird reason I don't
know 80% of these people who have demand
deposits or bank notes come and want to
switch their money for gold this bank is
going to run out of gold and that's a
bank run and and and there's there's a
couple of reasons why that's really bad
what is all of a sudden these these
demand deposit accounts all of a sudden
don't seem to be that great because
you're not really getting your gold on
demand because more people are asking
for gold then there is gold and then the
other problem is all of a sudden
everyone will lose confidence in the
system and everyone's going to think boy
these banks that have these nice vault
looking buildings maybe they're not as
safe as I thought so everyone is going
to start pulling their money out and
that's called a bank run so in this
example if I assume that this loan is
really worth three hundred gold pieces
and it's really going to be paid back
and this loan right is really worth 100
gold pieces and it really will be paid
back this Bank is solvent it has more
assets than it does liabilities so it
has if it has enough time it will be
able to pay back
all of its liabilities but if all of
these people all of a sudden come in and
want not just 500 gold pieces if they
want if they want 600 gold pieces right
there oh actually 700 so if they want
600 gold pieces all of a sudden everyone
is going to lose confidence in the
system these people probably have been
unable to get that they're probably
gonna want all their money back so then
all of these liabilities are going to
come due and then maybe the bank is
going to have to try to sell these asset
this these loans to someone else or
maybe try to collect from someone but as
you can imagine it's a whole it's a big
mess and the whole system that which is
depending on confidence will just start
to crumble but anyway the the initial
question is what is the limit to how
much you can expand the asset and the
liability side of the balance sheet just
by creating these loans and these
deposit accounts and that limit is
driven by the reserve ratio whatever the
regulator's set anyway I'll see you in
the next video